[Music]  [Applause]  someone there look at this all right  introducing axel the latest in military  protection featuring facial recognition  on war weapon systems and owner pairing  capabilities it's paired now the cake is  some control of the entire project  you wanna play all right let's go  I want to show you something hello isn't  talked to it  yeah stay shook a boy  do you so everything I said but it  somebody spent a lot of money on them  they gotta village before I don't think  it's owner deserves to get them back  I need to know what it's doing it's  evolving way beyond expectation that's  my dog I want him back  launch the drugs  come on he needs our help  what you should do is turn it in it's  not finders keepers you got to stay down  all right  it's a robot an intelligent robot he  feels things  sending you the new location move in for  retrieval  [Music]  order this together  you  you